en el vídeo de síntesis por
deshidratación vimos como podíamos
empezar con una molécula de glucosa y a
través de la síntesis por deshidratación
formar un enlace con otra molécula de
glucosa y simplemente haciendo esto
obtenemos un disacárido ok si estas dos
son moléculas de glucosa entonces esto
de aquí sería maltosa pero no nos
tenemos que detener ahí podríamos seguir
haciendo enlaces con otras glucosa y
formar una cadena más larga y estas
cosas en los que tomas monosacáridos y
el monosacárido más simple que hay es la
glucosa estas cosas en las que tomamos
monosacáridos y formamos una cadena se
llaman polisacáridos
paul y zachary 2 y la verdad es que hay
muchísimos ejemplos de polisacáridos
todo a tu alrededor
en especial hay muchos ejemplos de
polisacáridos que son derivados de la
glucosa por ejemplo aquí tenemos puré de
papas y el puré de papas es casi puro
almidón y el almidón es básicamente
puras cadenas de glucosa aunque hay el
puré de papas es almidón
ahora por otro lado el esqueleto de los
insectos y por ejemplo cosas como las
langostas incluso las alas de esta mosca
están conformadas por quitina y la
quitina también es un polisacárido está
hecha básicamente de puras cadenas de
una modificación de la glucosa y además
muy similar al algodón también en todos
nuestros músculos tenemos glucógeno que
es la forma en la que almacenamos
energía en los músculos y también
tenemos celulosa a nuestro alrededor por
todos lados
déjame lo escribo por aquí
los a la celulosa está en serio
básicamente todo a tu alrededor es de lo
que está constituido el papel y la
madera y está en todas las paredes
celulares de las plantas por acá tenemos
una foto de algodón del algodón en su
forma natural y bueno el algodón es la
forma más pura de encontrar celulosa ok
porque es básicamente 90% celulosa y
bueno si hacemos un acercamiento a una
fibra de algodón que sería cómo hacer un
acercamiento a una fibra de celulosa
aquí lo que veríamos son puras cadenas
de glucosa ok esta molécula de aquí es
una molécula de glucosa
y por aquí tenemos otra molécula de
glucosa
y toda esta cadena de moléculas de
glucosa se formó a través de la síntesis
por deshidratación ahora la gran
diferencia entre el almidón y la
celulosa es que el almidón se forma tal
cual como lo vimos en el vídeo de
síntesis por deshidratación mientras que
aquí en la celulosa unas moléculas de
glucosa están volteadas por aquí en esta
molécula de glucosa este oxígeno está
apuntando hacia acá mientras que aquí
ese oxígeno está apuntando hacia el otro
lado y luego este oxígeno apunta hacia
acá y este oxígeno hacia acá y bueno te
puedes poner a buscar en internet cosas
acerca de la celulosa es muy interesante
pero lo que realmente le da estructura
al algodón son estos enlaces de
hidrógeno ok
estos enlaces de hidrógeno que se forman
entre este oxígeno que es muy electro
negativo y que entonces tiene una carga
presión negativa
estos hidrógenos que tienen una carga
parcial positiva y esto es lo que
realmente le da estructura al algodón
así es que estos polisacáridos son muy
interesantes pero una cosa que nos
podemos preguntar es cómo le hacemos
nosotros para romper estos enlaces si
fuera yo a comerme este puré de papas
como le haría yo eventualmente para
transformarlo en glucosa y poder usar
esa energía y bueno en realidad eso
sucede a través de la hidrólisis
hidrólisis
y esta palabra hidrólisis también la
podemos partir en pedazos esta parte de
aquí dice libro y eso nos dice
directamente que tiene algo que ver con
el agua pero luego tenemos por aquí
lisis
y siempre que nos encontremos con lisis
significa que vamos a partir algo así es
que esta palabra nos dice que vamos a
partir algo utilizando agua y eso es
exactamente lo que sucede en la
hidrólisis si tenemos por aquí un
polisacárido y le agregamos agua a esta
molécula de agua va a poder romper uno
de estos enlaces de la cadena así es que
vamos a terminar con algo de este estilo
y bueno estas dos cadenas por supuesto
que pueden seguir mucho hacia los dos
lados y bueno vamos a terminar con algo
que se ve más o menos de este estilo
así es que esencialmente esta molécula
de agua se partió a la mitad para partir
a la cadena en dos pedazos es
básicamente el proceso inverso a la
síntesis por deshidratación y ahora
vamos a entenderlo un poco más a fondo
vamos a ver exactamente qué es lo que
sucede
y esto de aquí es maltosa es un día
querido y es simplemente dos moléculas
de glucosa enlazadas ahora si hubiéramos
seguido haciendo esto si por aquí
tuviéramos otra molécula de glucosa
enlazada y por aquí otra molécula de
glucosa enlazada también y así se
siguiera la cadena entonces tendríamos
almidón o tal vez glucógeno ahora si
esta molécula estuviera volteada y la
siguiente molécula estuviera normal y
después tuviéramos otra molécula
volteada y así se siguiera con unas
volteadas y otras no entonces podríamos
estar hablando de la celulosa pero por
el momento detengámonos a pensar en con
qué mecanismo podría llegar a ser que se
rompiera uno de estos enlaces y en
realidad se trata de la reacción inversa
de la síntesis por deshidratación y así
es que va a ser simplemente un repaso
rápido
empezamos por aquí con este oxígeno que
tiene 2
pares de electrones libres y siempre
existe la posibilidad de que si choca de
la forma correcta este par de electrones
libres se queden con algún protón de
hidrógeno que se encuentra por ahí
flotando en la solución porque ya
estamos suponiendo que esto sucede en
una solución acuosa o sea que esto está
sucediendo en el agua y puede tomar este
protón de alguna molécula de hidrógeno
que esté pasando por ahí y ahora cuando
sucede esto si es que sucede entonces lo
que tenemos es un enlace covalente con
un hidrógeno y este oxígeno ahora tiene
una carga positiva y ahora con respecto
a estos dos carbonos aunque nos vamos a
enfocar en este carbono ahora esto se ha
convertido en algo que en química le
llamamos un buen grupo saliente ok
porque este oxígeno tiene una carga
positiva y de por si el oxígeno es muy
electro negativo entonces el oxígeno
quiere
quedarse con todos los electrones de
este enlace así es que si las cosas
chocan de la forma correcta si las cosas
interactúan de la forma correcta puede
ser que llegue otra molécula de agua por
ahí que tiene sus dos pares de
electrones libres y justo aquí es donde
es muy importante la molécula de agua
extra que tenemos en la hidrólisis así
es que digamos que esta molécula de agua
es simplemente otra molécula de agua
pasando justo de la forma correcta por
aquí este oxígeno podría formar un
enlace con este carbono y justo en este
momento el carbono dice ok me están
compartiendo algunos electrones por aquí
así es que no necesito tanto estos
electrones por acá suelta estos
electrones y se los queda el oxígeno y
entonces que tenemos aquí bueno pues lo
podemos ver así bueno ahora vamos a
ponerle colores a todas las cosas por
aquí este enlace
este enlace de aquí este oxígeno vea que
es este oxígeno ve aquí y como podemos
ver aquí este oxígeno tiene otro enlace
con un hidrógeno y al momento de hacer
este enlace también tiene una carga
positiva y ahora este enlace de aquí los
dos electrones se quedaron en este
oxígeno este oxígeno que es este oxígeno
y finalmente este hidrógeno de aquí que
es el protón que tomó este oxígeno es
este hidrógeno de acá y ahora como
estábamos diciendo este oxígeno tomó un
protón de la solución
este protón pero ahora este oxígeno
puede regresar un protón de hidrógeno a
la solución cualquier molécula de agua
que pase por aquí puede tomar uno de
estos dos protones y transformarse en
una molécula de hidrógeno así es que en
total tomamos un protón de hidrógeno
pero también podemos regresar
de hidrógeno y entonces solo necesitamos
esta molécula de agua para romper este
enlace
y este hidrógeno de aquí puede pasar
alguna molécula de agua y transformarse
en hidronew ok y listo ya terminamos ya
tenemos aquí dos moléculas separadas de
glucosa y ya rompimos el enlace aunque
bueno tal vez estas dos en realidad
formaban parte de una cadena más larga y
entonces lo único que hicimos fue partir
a la cadena en dos pero si en efecto era
una molécula de maltosa como tenemos
aquí entonces sí ya separamos a la
maltosa en dos moléculas individuales de
glucosa ahora no necesariamente tenía
que ser maltosa también podría ser por
ejemplo sacarosa y entonces hubiéramos
partido a la sacarosa a través de la
hidrólisis en una molécula de glucosa y
una molécula de fructosa ok así es que
la hidrólisis es una reacción muy
importante en biología